today is uh not a day
like any other and i'm not this i'm not
doing a passover seder i know many of my
friends will will
recognize that line from passover no uh
today is not a day like any other for
different reasons
yesterday yes donald trump spoke
publicly again
yes we are going to discuss it yes i am
going to play some clips but
donald trump has now gone over a line
where he is just five and a half weeks
away from the election
refusing to say that there will be a
peaceful transition of power
should he lose he will not commit to a
peaceful transition
now when you combine this with our
earlier story from the top of the show
about donald trump's uh contingency plan
for how to retain power even if he loses
you have to at this point start paying
attention this was a press briefing i
guess it was
sort of under the umbrella of a
coronavirus press briefing although
on coronavirus trump says the same thing
every time which is we're doing great
everything's fine on the virus and then
the questions
started from the press corps and donald
trump was asked will you commit
to a peaceful transfer of power and
donald trump refuses to commit to it and
he's a wannabe dictator and we should
all be very very scared
when loser draw in this election will
you commit here today
for a peaceful trans referral of power
after the election
and there has been rioting in louisville
there's been rioting in many cities
across this country
red and your so-called red and blue
states will you commit to making sure
that there is a peaceful transferal of
power
after the election well we're gonna have
to see what happens you know that i've
been complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster and
but people are rioting do you commit to
making sure that there's a peaceful
transfer
we want to have get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very trans we'll have
a very
peaceful there won't be a transfer
frankly there'll be a continuation
the ballots are out of control you know
it and you know who knows it better than
anybody else the democrats know it
better than anybody else go ahead
now the guy asking the questions saying
hey but people are rioting so will you
commit to a peaceful transition
it's actually a non-sequitur and and you
know we have protests that are mostly
peaceful
and now there is unrest because of
what's going on with brianna taylor in
kentucky which we already talked about
i don't really love the framing of will
you commit to a peaceful transfer of
power because there are riots it's like
well hold on will you commit to a
peaceful transfer of power
is really the full question you don't
need anything else with it but
this is the red alert the the reaction
from donald trump we don't have to
speculate that donald trump might not
leave
or will try not to leave to be to be
clear because he's saying it in broad
daylight i have to see the results first
before i commit to a peaceful transfer
of power
even if i lose when trump says
the way it will be peaceful is if we
don't have the ballots he's referring to
vote absentee by mail which trump thinks
would lead to him winning he is
essentially saying
if the results are that i won we will
have a peaceful transition
in that there will be no transition
because if the election is fair i will
win
this is an extraordinary dangerous thing
to say
uh all standard bullet points apply
everybody has to vote this is not a
rehearsal
this is happening he's doing it it's
outrageous
and uh it it didn't get uh any less
crazy just a couple of other clips
donald trump was told
during the briefing that prince harry
and meghan markle
will not be supporting him and trump
just insults meghan markle mr president
uh prince harry and meghan markle uh
chimed in on the u.s election and
essentially encouraged people to vote
for joe biden
let me get your reaction to that i'm not
a fan of hers
and i would say this
and she probably has heard that but uh
i wish a lot of luck
to harry because he's gonna need it this
is a president
speaking this way and then trump brings
up and we'll discuss this later
that mixing the flu with the
china virus as he calls it will be
interesting
the flu when it's mixed with covid
or china virus is uh going to be very
interesting to see what happens but
interesting is certainly an interesting
way to describe it and then
even the end of this press briefing is
wild trump
abruptly says as the questions start
coming in about brianna taylor
trump says he has to go take an
emergency phone call and walks away and
when reporter john roberts asks him
who's the phone call with
trump just says it's very
phone important i'm going to let scott
and harry finish up
larry's going to talk about it
so i'll be uh i'll be back i will see
you tomorrow
a big day just one more question on
brianna taylor we're in a time right now
where americans feel like we are on this
parenthood i have a
mr president just one more question if i
can't briana taylor
okay so that's just a little bit of the
the the flavor the tone but the big
thing here is
donald trump is refusing to say he will
leave peacefully if he loses the man has
come to the end of the line
and he knows biden could win
biden could win and he is going to pull
out all the stops
and see if he can get away with it and
why wouldn't he he's gotten
away with so much so far why wouldn't he
try it
and the ironic thing is we talk about
projection constantly
if biden wins trump will call that a
coup
that's what trump will say is a coup
they will always
accuse you of what they are actually
doing now the truth
here is um donald trump
has always had this perspective what i
mean is
trump still hasn't accepted the results
of 2016
when he won trump still does not accept
that he really lost to hillary by
millions of votes
he continues to say well i won
electorally hugely
and even on the popular vote it was
rigged
buses from massachusetts to new
hampshire it's like well hold on
what are you talking about how would
that how would that even affect the
popular vote first of all if people are
voting in the wrong state
but in any case he still has not
accepted the results of an election he
won
democracy is really at risk here and
certainly donald trump will do
everything he can not to accept the
results
of an election if he loses one of our
sponsors today
is monk pack keto granola bars and they
are giving you 20
off when you go to davidpakman.com
snack and use the coupon code pacman
you know a lot of these uh low-carb
snack bars
have a reputation for not tasting great
but
i can tell you from trying these myself
that that is not the case with the monk
pack
keto granola bars they taste just as
good
if not better than the sugar-filled
chewy granola bars that many of us love
but these contain only one gram of sugar
two net carbs
only 140 calories they're completely
plant-based and gluten-free
great for anybody following a low-carb
diet
but also perfect for anybody like me
who's just trying to
reduce sugar intake which i think is a
good thing i've been working
on a box of these at home they're
delicious soft chewy texture
bunch of great flavors including peanut
butter coconut cocoa chip which
is my personal favorite it's great for a
quick breakfast
a snack in the afternoon i have been
loving these
you can get to their website by going to
davidpakman.com
snack the link is under this video and
you'll get twenty percent off when you
use the coupon code
pacman